[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a number 105. no i
don't say 105 i say 105. yes you do yes
i do
all right
the discord question this week is
speculation
children who more strongly resemble
their father are more likely to survive
because he is more certain they are his
if true would you expect to see pressure
towards a stronger expression of
paternal genes in terms of physical
appearance
interesting this was a topic of
discussion in
my
graduate laboratory
the
alexander lab
insect division where most of us did not
study insects because that was just kind
of the gathering place for renegades but
anyway um well dick alexander studied
insects and so some of he was the major
advisor for some of the people there um
but he was on my committee and i was
there even though
i studied frogs he started bats yeah
they were bird people they were mammal
people there were some insects there
were so many scared people periodicals
which are insects so
um in any case
the logic actually came out different
than you're suggesting here the logic is
that actually babies don't look human to
obscure
their paternity
which on the one hand i see the logic of
your question but the point is if no
baby looks human
then fathers are less likely to
interpret the look of their
unearthly looking child as indicative of
it not being their child
that's the way the logic goes rather
than
a
arms race in which children
are
favored to express uh genes that
highlight
the paternal features
come again
the point was there was no
good way
for children
to for babies to advertise
their
um
phenotypic characteristics that would
make them
uh
appear to be more likely the
it's hard to know what terminology to
use here
if the idea is that a child that does
not look like its father is more likely
to come to harm evolutionary
evolutionarily speaking
then the discord question suggests why
doesn't the baby then advertise the
characteristics that would reassure its
putative father that the putative father
was in fact the actual genetic father of
the travertise and specifically like
what you know
maybe why doesn't at least as as a
newborn or as a young child
kids more closely resemble their fathers
and their mothers since there's no
uncertainty of maternity possible right
the problem is that the benefit that one
imagines from the child reassuring their
putative father
is more than erased by the danger of
alerting a putative father that he is
not in fact the father so the point is
actually pulls in the direction of
not saying much about parentage well
well
expect predicting that
there won't be any imprinting of
paternal or maternal genes to express
phenotype
that more closely resembles mom or dad
in newborns
but what we would predict and what we do
in fact see um in in many cultures
including our own
is the software layer takes over right
now we are you know you would predict
that
uh
the
the
family of the mother of a newborn
would be likely to exclaim enjoy and
delight how much the new baby looks like
dad yes right whether or not the new
babies whether or not the new baby does
in fact look like that right if you know
if mom is pair bonded um and you know
hopefully with or without any evidence
that there was any cheating going on um
you would predict that there would be a
lot of exclamations about um how dad
looking the baby looks as opposed to
how mom looked in the baby looks at
least right at first right now i will
add one
little extra goodie here which is
i believe that for similar reasons you
would actually imagine that when women
cheat they tend to cheat with men who
look like their partners because it will
tend to well it will obviously
predispose the um
the babies to look enough like the
uh investing parent to not trigger
um insecurities yeah i don't i don't
know if this is true it's an interesting
contradiction and it could have
something to do with why uh
this would be in the case of women why
some women would have a type
yeah i was thinking that um but i mean i
could all i can see this argument going
the opposite direction as well and um
you know maybe you would want to get
into more predictions that would have to
avoid hand waving territory
around under what circumstances do you
are you attracted to type as opposed to
to you know something broader or even
anti-type
right yeah but
yeah maybe
all right all right so that was that was
the discord question here is the first
question that was submitted today
love you too wait a minute
i mean so far so good
um oh somehow i'm not signed in anymore
oh okay i know i can read this first
question but then i have to get resigned
in because i can't all my ordering is
gone this was not the first question but
i'm gonna read it and then i gotta what
happened okay love you too thank you for
all the sanity during these hard times
a have you read the recent study
indicating spike impairs dna damage
repair what implications does this have
for the vaccine
and how long be how long do you think
the body will produce spike after the
mrna vaccine i can't find any reliable
answers on this
so i'm going to take you let you take
the lead on this while i all right
so i would say a number of things a
anytime we have an implication of spike
protein which we do in many of the
questions surrounding covid you have to
ask yourself
to what extent are the vaccines distinct
from the pathogen itself and there will
be some important distinctions
right so we've got
in the case of the vaccines
we have the introduction of either dna
or rna that causes the
production of spike protein which is
supposed to lodge in the cell surface we
know that it doesn't always stick and so
there's some free-floating
spike in the case of vaccines
we
don't know what happens as far as i know
we don't know what happens in the case
of an actual infection there's spike
protein produced cells that have been
infected are presumably
killed and cleaned up by
cytotoxic t cells for example
and macrophages and so there's a
question about is there free floating
spike
associated with um
with
the infection
and then the big question the thing that
i think is hard to spot
is we've got this result that says
spike protein interferes with dna repair
now on the one hand that could be dire
if the spike protein is
highly likely to disrupt repair and a
small amount of spike protein does it
and the spike protein ends up
circulating around the body and so
there's a lot of dna repair disrupted on
the other hand if it's only in a small
number of cells it may not be a
significant effect right it'll be an
effect it will damage some cells you
know it can cause an occasional cancer
presumably
but the real question and one of the
questions that i think underlies
the whole issue of the vaccine design
is that when you take
mrnas for example
and you coat them with the lipid
nanoparticles and you dump them into
the body
so that they will be taken up by cells
there's no good way to control
how much gets taken up and by what cells
this is a very haphazard process and
what that means is that for the vaccines
to be effective in a case where they are
taken up very little
if you imagine a bell curve
of uptake right where over here you have
very low uptake
over here you have very low uptake here
you have average uptake and here you
have very high uptake
right in order for people in the low
uptake group
to have gotten enough to do the job of
the vaccine then those who are in the
average and high uptake group will have
gotten a whole heck of a lot right and
so the point is this isn't i don't know
enough about individual variation in
physiological response in terms of what
people
can or do are up taking
to individually tailor dosages right and
everything i think we've seen suggest
that these vaccines a
don't stay where we wanted them to stay
and b are taken up by all kinds of
different tissues and so so there is a
question on that first point they don't
stay where they're supposed to stay
there's this question of whether or not
this is a um
perhaps largely perhaps almost
exclusively a human error problem with
regard to the way in which
uh the vaccines are given
the
the remember it's not is it aspirate
yeah aspiration yeah it is asking
questions
this is this is one issue but i think
the basic
first of all you are a creature of 30
trillion 40 trillion cells okay that's a
very large number it's very hard for the
human mind to wrap itself around that
kind of number so we have a cartoonish
sense about how many cells that is and
it's a very wrong and misleading sense
to have
this i mean the thing is the lipid
nanoparticles don't have
an address on them
right there's nothing that targets them
at particular cells they go where they
go and they get absorbed and the
ribosomes which are in virtually every
cell
then transcribe the message and so they
get in the message gets transcribed
the immune system sees it and it does
its thing but the point is it's such a
haphazard process that the amount of
spike protein produced
given two individuals that had a
different physiological reaction of the
vaccine
is liable to be large and so
i don't the truth is i saw this report
it was delivered in very alarmist terms
oh my god the spike protein disrupts dna
repair well dna repair is very important
and the spike protein disrupting it is
therefore not good on the other hand
you can disrupt virtually any process in
a tiny number of cells and not have a
big effect on the body or if you do it
in a large number of cells the likely
effect is going to be much bigger and so
i don't think we have a good sense about
how widespread this is likely to be so
it's certainly an interesting scale on
any of these issues
yeah yeah it's
certainly interesting
there's no way it could possibly be good
right and it could be very very bad but
i don't think we know that it is very
very bad
all right
is there a safe and sane country which
is not sweden to go to i'm in germany
will it get better after the winter
thank you for all your work
interesting um this is from anina
someone named nina um
that she i think is excluding sweden and
i wonder
i wonder why
um we were just talking this week about
um how interesting it is that sweden
seemed to have
kind of explicitly and with intention
gone the anti-authoritarian route
throughout this and was sort of
roundly mocked by many uh in early
pandemic and certainly has had some
spikes at some moments when other
countries weren't but has by and large
done
pretty damn well for itself and it has
not it is
it never it
never did lockdowns it i didn't even
have mask mandates and actually i'll
just say this and this is exactly not
about the question because she says not
sweden but um uh i asked a friend of
ours uh for grad school who's actually
lived in sweden for the last several
years and i think summer of last year
i was like what what's going on there
like what what what is what is the
swedish government doing like all over
the rest of the of the weird world
they're at least mask at this point i
was i was convinced that masks were um
were doing a lot of good
and she said our friend said in response
you know the swedish government
nose
actually has cultivated
in the populace of sweden um
the
the the response that if it says you
must do something the populace will do
it
and in part it has cultivated that by
never overreaching it does not
say you have to do things when it's
actually kind of just strongly
encouraging to do things and so her take
was uh the student government is is
playing this cool and playing it hands
off and it reserves the right to say
actually now now you gotta
and um
because it never abuses that power it
actually has it in reserve in a way that
you know clearly at some level
the american government is playing you
know trying all sorts of tricks pulling
all sorts of stupid tricks out of its
bag that aren't working it very well
because because they they play that
trick too often they play this they they
show their hand and they play the same
card over and over and over again where
they say you gotta why just because we
say so
try again
yeah
well i think there are a couple things
uh tied up in here one there's a
question of why exclude sweden because
it might be the answer to the question
two is
the
question that i
fear we will never have the answer to
but whether
this has been the greatest lesson and
welcomed the complex systems ever
devised and that basically our
interventions the net impact of them
will have been negative
um and that we would have actually been
better off if we had um
not intervened and i'm not saying that
this is a good policy because there has
been a tremendous amount of death and
that is
very unfortunate but the point is it was
never a threat
uh to the population as a whole
it was a threat to the old and infirm
and
herd immunity is a real phenomenon and
so
there's a question about you know do you
want to play this game indefinitely or
do you want
it to run its course and to be done with
it and if we're willing to play this
game with this path agenda we're going
to you know it's going to be easy to
convince a whole lot of people to play
it with others because
frankly as much as as much
death and destruction as this particular
virus seems to have brought it's hardly
the worst pathogen we've encountered oh
yeah
it's not that at all um it's bad but the
point is in part you know we've focused
on it in a way that we typically ignore
harms and
so anyway i guess what i would say is i
don't know that we will ever have a
proper analysis of the net effect of our
interventions but
let's say that the interventions
were
needed and desirable and reduced harm
but some countries didn't
employ them right
there still
would be an argument now if he's looking
for a country
that one could go to a country that did
nothing and therefore basically had
accumulated a lot of immune people by
virtue of having had cova that might be
the place to move to now even if the
policy that got there was a mistake
right um yes
i don't know
i don't know which
those countries are you know mexico
seems appealing
um and not you know they didn't they
didn't have that they didn't do
hands-off but they have been willing to
not just follow in lockstep what the who
says yeah for instance you know they
have in at least in places um given out
both prophylactic and early treatment
packs that included um you know drugs
that were not um being given for you
know the reason that they are stated as
the only reason they should be given
yeah um
and
where else though i don't i don't know
places in africa yeah yeah so many so
many countries in africa i don't i feel
like there's going to be variation
um but
uh sort of
within the tropics tropical africa
yeah seems to have
seems to have done done less and
suffered less from covid for various
reasons it can be vitamin d can be part
of it you know an endogenous reason it
can be ivermectin being used for
parasites it can be a lot of different
reasons but nonetheless um i don't think
there's a good answer to this question i
mean basically i think for the first
time in human history we are stuck with
the question of there's nowhere to run
what do you do and the answer is you
fight that's what you do um
but
uh
no i don't i don't think it's a good
place to go but you know yes you
there it depends what you're trying to
avoid
what your top priority is here there
might be solutions to to that one thing
yeah
okay next question
um this actually is more of a comment
for an individual it is surely best to
live on your feet
next to live on your knees
then to die on your feet and worst to
die on your knees
but at the population level
sometimes dying on your feet paves the
way for and inspires many others to live
on theirs
it's very well said and uh i would say
this is another
place where a an understanding that um
lineage is not a vague term that it is a
a an evolutionary entity
and it is the thing that selection cares
about is key because
what we find is that people behave in
ways where they may die on their feet so
others may live on their feet and that
is not a paradox or a non-sequitur or
any of those things it's a historical
process and so
it does tell us something about what our
choices are but i think your your
taxonomy is a good one yeah
i agree as well
have either of you heard of a mass
formation professor matthias desmet
speaks of this thanks for the continued
sharing of sanity and the person writing
links to um
a piece
about dr matthias desmond and i'm just
going to read the four conditions that
this person um
thomas m casey
no thomas
sorry thomas casey says about what what
the four conditions are four conditions
need to be present to create mass
formation
one
there needs to be a lot of socially
isolated people or people who experience
a lack of social bond
two
people who experience a lack of
sense-making unable to come to sensible
conclusions
three there was a lot of free-floating
anxiety free-floating because there's
nothing to connect their anxiety to no
focal point unable to identify what's
causing it and so no way to deal with it
and four there's also a lot of
free-floating psychological discontent
people may experience their daily lives
as lacking any purpose or meaning
so we've certainly got
met all of those uh four things you want
to say something more about mass
formation
yeah i am
persuaded there's something important in
this model i've been tracking it for i
don't know a month month and a half
and the idea is that what we are seeing
are people behaving under something akin
to hypnosis hypnosis
a kind of hypnosis that kicks in when
these conditions uh attain
and
i must say
i don't
feel that you and i are under this
hypnosis and i do feel that we are
encountering a world full of people that
is behaving almost as if they are
sleepwalking on autopilot under some
kind of hypnosis
who are not in many cases
acting according to their own character
and values
and so this is very alarming
um
and you know i think we've been we've
been trying to raise the alarm about
this you know for example i think we
were
uh we may have been
the first if not we were very early in
pointing out
that this trope about portraying
uh some segment of society as
disease-ridden
right as sub-human and disease-ridden
is extremely ominous because it is the
precursor to behaviors in which you do
away with such people and you are
entitled to do away with those people
for one thing you don't have to worry
too much about them because they weren't
even fully human to begin with and for
another thing they are causing disease
and therefore each one of them
represents like a walking source of
death yeah there's so many reasons
they're reasons that they're gross and
dispensable right and so we now see this
portrayal again and again i saw it as
recently as today in uh
an article
i believe it was the washington
post talking about the number of um
deaths this year as compared to last
year which is something i want to return
to
maybe next live stream i think wall
street journal maybe but it was oh maybe
it was the wall street journal
but in any case it very clearly paints a
picture that is not borne out by the
evidence at all um in which yes it's
those pesky unvaccinated who are causing
the rest of us to be in danger of this
deadly disease and it's like that story
doesn't even add up right of course as
many people have recognized there's
something weird about a vaccine that
requires other people to get it in order
for it to work to protect you
um right that's not a high quality
vaccine at the very least
it's uh lackluster might not be
deserving of the name
right maybe we
might not have been deserving of an
experiment in which we attempt to
vaccinate the entire world but
okay
um so anyway yes i mass formation
is well worth tracking i don't know that
it's a hundred percent accurate as a
model but i will say if you walk around
thinking am i dealing with um
hypnotized people and is that why
they're behaving this way it seems to be
more uh enlightening than it is
confusing
so anyway keep tracking it
where are we one year from now
what will the state of the world look
like
thank you we greatly appreciate you
taking the time each week
this from someone whose
name here is don't distance from nature
well i mean as a planet a year from now
we're going to be right here
[Music]
i
mean
can you map out for us where we're going
to be three months from now as a planet
i mean yeah wait oh no get the problem
that's bad
he's gonna tear the whole thing down i'm
really glad i tightened that otherwise
we could have had a little catastrophe a
catastrophe is what we could have had
um yes uh for those of you who are just
listening and not watching nothing
happening here oh right in the q a so
well there could be people with their
eyes closed
at this point we got we got cat hour
here we do yeah um
where are we going to be a year from now
i besides right besides here i shudder
to think i don't think these people have
left themselves
a
graceful exit from this authoritarian
nonsense and
um
uh i i worry about where we're gonna be
i also worry
that the places that you would think
would be most immune to this garbage
seem to be
especially if they're in the southern
hemisphere
engaged in
absolutely
remarkable and self-defeating
in places with like almost no cases of
covet in which they're claiming that you
know the death of someone past their
life expectancy is a tragedy and
warrants shutting down cities and such
so it's right i mean it may be a tragedy
but uh destroying civilization over it
is not um
not obviously a reasonable thing to do
yeah so i mean so i've been i have been
trying i i have
i have not been in an optimistic frame
of mind for a couple of weeks about
where we're going to be in a year and
what this all means about
what this all means about humanity
because if we get out of this one
there's going to be another one and
there needs
there will need to be
a reckoning there will need to be a
moment in which everyone who went
authoritarian who went ash positive who
said
you know that mile long line is shorter
than the inch long line because msnbc
told me so
um looks themselves in the mirror and
says
i did that
i fell for it
i stated it publicly
i was wrong i shamed people who didn't
need to be shamed who shouldn't have
been shamed i was part of the problem i
should not fall prey to that part of
myself again what do i need to do
i'm worried that that reckoning even if
we get out of this is not gonna is not
gonna happen so i say that that probably
should have come second but you know
the one of the few things that gives me
some hope right now of emerging from
this one which again isn't a solution
because we need we need it not to be
able to happen like this again
but
it is now ever more widely recognized
that
um
these vaccines have very low efficacy
put aside the safety questions entirely
for the moment that there you know even
that crazy atlantic thing that i read
from in the first hour says your
antibodies peak three weeks after like
yeah and you know some research that we
talked about a couple of weeks ago
said two to three weeks two to three
months after your second dose you're
already getting waning
waning immunity and that's why they're
talking about boosters
um but
it is my sense
because of people we talk to and because
of the people that people we talk to
talk to and so yes this is sort of
anecdotal but it is my sense that there
are
a lot of people
who
got vaccinated as they were supposed to
were dutiful about it didn't ask too
many questions or maybe they did and
they still decide to get vaccinated and
because of what they have seen since
could be about injury it could be about
the lies from the politicians or the
public health authorities or the
recognition that they appear to have
signed up for an unending treadmill as
opposed to one and done and we're out of
this could be for a lot of reasons but
that a lot of people who signed up for
the first two are not going to do
boosters
i think that that is why i think that
that the government as
incompetent as it seems in many regards
can read
that wind well enough right now that
that is why we have not seen mandatory
boosters
that frankly if you got vaccinated in
february of this year the idea that
you're still considered fully vaccinated
is laughable
whatever fully vaccinated may have meant
at the time well but no wait is is
laughable and so
at what point does your you know your
vax card that is getting into like
restaurants in seattle which you can't
go into if you're not vaccinated at this
point for instance at what point does
that require a booster to get you in
a lot of people who got vaccinated
aren't going to do with do with boosters
and then we're going to have an even
larger number of people who are saying
wait a minute why are my civil liberties
being curtailed why am i one of the
dirty ones now i even followed your
orders the first time and now i didn't
follow them enough even though your
orders just have gotten stupider and
stupider
so you know that that i think is what
can break here um that there it's it's
one thing to call those of us who who
never got the jab
um dirty and vermin and the reason that
the thing is continuing and all of this
all of which is untrue
um but it's quite it's going to be quite
another slight of hand for them to
convince
everyone who's eagerly signing up for
boosters
um that even the people who got their
first two and just are not signing up
for infinite boosters more
are also dirty and vermin and causing
the problem
yes
uh
to the extent
that this is
initially about a pathogen and it is now
about something else that involves at
least compliance yeah it may also
involve
i don't know the content of these
uh inoculations um but
you know and the destruction of the
control group so that we can't ever see
what the consequence of this was
the
question about
i don't know how to say it delicately
right the vaccine card thing and the
booster thing and the fact that some
people will not get a booster who did
get um
a the initial set of vaccinations and
you know look lots of people are in that
camp today but you know we're going to
see an arms race and they're going to
put on the pressure
to uh to get boosters and lots of people
will buckle for the same reasons that
they buckled the first time
which are that they want to
engage in normal life and this seems
this is the carrot that is going to be
offered
to allow them to engage in normal
behaviors whether or not it makes any
sense
and uh i don't know i don't know how
that game plays out but from the point
of view of does it make any sense to say
that you're fully vaccinated obviously
you know your your other point's a
really good one if three weeks is where
these things peak and it starts trailing
off there's such thing as fully
vaccinated there's are you at the peak
or are you somewhere else
and
the real point is that fully vaccinated
may be
the way people wearing masks that don't
have a positive effect may be a hallmark
of compliance more than it is an
immunological fact yeah i follow the
rules yeah why don't you why don't you
hi do you know much about the safety of
the whooping cough vaccine
my sister is having a baby soon and
wants me to get it i'm 26. thanks
interesting at 26 um you don't see where
you're where you're writing from but um
i would have thought that
basically a hundred percent very close
to 100 of 26 year old americans have
been vaccinated against whooping cough
as um as children
it's in the dpt vaccine is that right
yeah yeah exactly
um and that said like i remember there
was actually a pertussis outbreak in one
of our boys schools when they were very
young
but and i don't actually remember
i don't remember any of the details our
boys are both vaccinated against it as
their weave from long ago um so i
haven't actually never heard of an adult
pursuing the whooping cough vaccine and
that's um really that's
that's my only question i just don't
know to what degree it's it's
generated for
um i don't even remember if it's one of
the like the almost the neonate vaccines
or it's got a course over a few years
um i don't remember i can say i know
nothing specific about it i can say um
you know
two years ago
i would have said as far as i know it's
a safe vaccine
you know now the shenanigans i've seen
would cause me to do my own homework
before getting vaccinated presumably
it's a safe vaccine but you know
well i mean it of course
right i i agree with you exactly and um
you know what's the back so the fact
that we experienced with one of our boys
one of their schools there was an
outbreak as i remember it and just a
couple people maybe um
but that tells you
not much about the background rate of
pertussis i feel like
you pre-covered we used to hear in the
news national like oh a couple a couple
places a year there would be investors
outbreaks so you know if the background
rate where you are where your sister is
is
you know is basically zero if there
haven't been any outbreaks in forever
then that's that's a different situation
although you know air travel makes that
analysis tough to do yes people can
bring it in
um
yeah obviously we don't know your your
living situation but
um it does seem to me that the chances
that your being vaccinated protects uh
your sister's child from
a case of this
rare disease is so close to zero
that you ought to be able to have a
conversation if you really have a reason
not to want that vaccine um
yeah it's curious that that you're not
vaccinated right so that's you know that
that's there's a lot of a lot of the
backstory we don't know yeah and it also
seems like were
whooping cough
to show up
right you could take action then knowing
that you were not vaccinated
to protect your niece but
um
so i i don't know i i guess we don't
know just assumed the baby's gender
sex actually tell the gender babies
don't have gender i assumed that they
were a match
no it's the sister that's where you got
female from
you don't
well we're talking about a future case
of pertussis and i know that the future
is female oh wow
oh
that was good good escape though that's
a houdini like yes efficacy really
um right all right i don't remember
where we were but i think i think we've
delivered enough information i do too
um
what's the most surprising fact you
learned in evo devo for me it was that
over a hundred different types of eye
structures independently evolved love
you guys this is from chop citizen
um
you know
i so i
the one
my the favorite person that i had to
teach with um at evergreen was
this uh geneticist and developmental
biology he was really it was actually he
was a developmental biologist he also
taught genetics
um uh and he and i would teach
development and evolution together and
in fact one of the programs we taught
together was called development and
evolution colon something something
something
and we specifically chose that order so
as not to have it be mistaken for an evo
devo class and i had i had
less
concern about it but he
uh you know he had actually escaped you
know one of these very elite
institutions and come and come to
evergreen
and um you know just
you know said i'm not i'm not interested
in your shenanigans and games anymore
and what he had seen of the of the
discipline of evodeo had so unimpressed
him that he had the sense of like i
don't i don't want to be associated with
that i want to understand development i
understand evolution but um you know
calling it evo devo isn't that
interesting to me so i don't know i've
never taken a class called evo devo i
don't know
i don't know what is supposed to be
included in it but
um the you know over 100 different types
of eye structures independently evolved
is certainly fascinating and one thing
that that prompts me to think is
the
the fact that in um
like these cave fish
um that live in total darkness
um they they lose their eyes um not as
individuals but um you know they don't
have eyes and then gradually lose them
they're you know they population loses
population loses their eyes thank you
um but it's effectively a toggle
that like it's effectively a genetic
toggle and that if those pipe you know
if the if the ceiling collapses and you
know they're in the light again
um
very quickly you know it doesn't take
they don't regrow eyes slowly over over
generations the eyes are either on or
off and just fascinating to me like that
struck me as very surprising that there
would be a discreet toggle like that on
something as complex as an eye in a
lineage which had already evolved the
eyes over
right that had a highly refined eye
exactly yeah on the other hand i mean
that really is the key message of of evo
devo is
that information most information is
latent and the subset of information
that is not latent is what allows you to
be
a an organized creature rather than a
puddle of similar cells right and you
know
yeast
i'm sure there are yeast biologists out
there who will shake their fist at me
for saying this but you know yeast kind
of is a puddle of similar cells it's a
colonial phenomenon rather than an
organism and the point is the organismal
nature of critters so you're you're
restricting the use of the word organism
to multicellular with differentiation
between cells well like i
let's yes i am
in this case i'm saying yes an organism
is a differentiated creature now is this
differentiated between different types
of cell types cell types and
multicellular right the reason i'm
hesitant is because i would also call a
yeast cell an organism
right but the point is the colony isn't
exactly an organism and so it's one of
these
distinctions that i'm not sure we have
rich enough language but the basic point
is but it's a fascinating one because it
changes all sorts of things about shared
fate and you know what individual cells
are going to do and
right and the colonial stuff is way more
interesting than we give it credit for
as well in fact i have long argued that
things uh like um conjugation in
bacteria where bacteria are exchanging
plasmids and things have to do with the
fact that those colonies of organisms
have an organismal nature to them that
we don't typically recognize right we
see it happen but we don't understand
its meaning
so anyway the point is
evo devo allows latency latency allows a
library to produce an organism by
encoding a subset and you know the fact
that you i mean the amazing fact is
developmentally your cells know where
they are
both by
chemical context right what signals
they're getting from neighboring cells
and a count of how many cell divisions
have taken them down their line from the
zygote and the combination of those
things tells them what subset of the
library to transcribe and that makes us
orders right so those two things
provide information about what to do
you can get from there to well what
happens if you damage some set of tissue
and then you can replace it right
if we cut a hole in your arm you can
replace it with cells that are
appropriate right if we cut off your arm
we can't right on the other hand there
are but in neither case do you get liver
cells trying it out right although in a
cancer you will get that sure but if you
have a wound on your arm or the wound is
your arm is missing in neither case does
the early attempt to wound heal which is
possible in the first case and not
possible in a second do you get um the
wrong cell type the wrong cell types
right there's a contingency program and
it's uh relevant
um and then you know in a few creatures
a few salamanders for example you can
get limb regeneration so proving that
it's possible so the fact that we don't
have it is interesting
in vertebrates not in invertebrates in
vertebrates uh it's almost unknown
except you get you can get whole limb
regeneration in um
amy madden's i think yeah salamanders
yeah um so anyway all i'm getting at is
that i actually think um
i hate that it's called evo devo and i
hate sort of the culture around it a
little bit maybe i don't hate it but i
don't love the culture around it but it
almost strikes me as the only
interesting thing that's happened
evolutionarily since 1976
is the discovery of this whole mechanism
that basically is the difference between
uh you know a cell and an organism
um
well i think i mean in a way
that the book that i love so much mary
jane westy reheard's book on phenotypic
plasticity is is
kind of a tome about evo devo
um
yeah you're right it's it's the you know
it's the evo devo coming from the evo
side rather than the devo side yeah yeah
exactly yeah
all right
what
i don't know what this question means
but it's next up so i will read it but i
don't actually i don't even know what
one of these words is what's the
adaptiveness of phatic questions and
answers p-h-a-t-i-c
where deception slash obfuscation slash
salesmanship slash abbreviation of one's
condition is expected
i think i might understand that more if
i look up phatic
is it related to emphatic that's that's
what i thought do you do you recognize
it you know no i don't um
i will say so i have a
over relating to communication used to
perform a social function rather than to
convey information or ideas
that's a useful word yeah yeah
um what's the adaptiveness of emphatic
questions and answers
where deception obfuscation salesmanship
abbreviation of one's condition is
expected
it's going to be entirely context
dependent isn't it it's not how i would
do the taxonomy here so i have a um a
module
where's the i don't i don't see a
taxonomy here
phatic
where
conveying information versus social
function that does that doesn't strike
me as natural
you don't like the word phatic you don't
like the description no i may like the
word phatic perfectly well but i don't
like it as an evolutionary division
here in other words i think it's useful
if that's fatigue's definition that's
cool that's very useful
to be able to describe things in that
category but the problem is that's not
evolutionarily where i would draw the
line okay oh good yeah um i would draw
the line at what i call um
perception-mediated selection yeah right
and the point is there are certain
things that are mediated by actual
interaction with the universe and there
are other things that are mediated by
the perception of a critter and they
behave very differently evolutionarily
and so the problem is that
fatigue here
excludes informational communication
where i would say informational
communication is perception mediated
and so anyway i would just draw the
categorization differently
yeah though boy there's a lot more to go
there let's let's let's move on to
that's very interesting
um
how is it possible that wild deer got
covered it seems unlikely that a deer
was in a closed space with an infected
human right love the show
um yeah the deer thing is so odd it
really is you know and the thing is i
expected it to be nonsense when i first
looked into the page i think we talked
briefly about it too right yeah i'm not
not convinced but it's not nonsense yeah
part of the work that i can see was done
correctly they corrected for exactly the
thing that i thought it was going to be
right i mean what that was or no maybe
it doesn't matter so they have
widespread distribution of it's called
their mule white tail
east coast white tails
um
widespread uh coveted in these creatures
too widespread for it to be plausible in
my opinion like if a population got it i
would expect that but for it to be
across the entire range especially given
that the pathogen doesn't transmit
outdoors right there's a problem yeah
what's going on and so what i expected
was that they had gone out to say are
there any wild creatures that get
coveted and they tested deer and came up
positive and reported
that's not the case they have
samples prior to the covent pandemic
which don't come up positive and then
they have samples afterwards so it's not
a question of they went out and they
found some other coronavirus that's
triggering their test
right but it's and it's not like a cycle
threshold issue
could be could be any one of a number of
things let's just say i'm very
suspicious that the result can't mean
what they seem to think it means but i'm
not convinced that they did the work
badly and therefore
it's an actual serious question and
maybe
i mean you know again and if it really
isn't all the deer um
then then
we have it like we we're living with it
yeah yeah look i i am not signing up for
this construction with a virus that
appears to have come out of a laboratory
because
it's always your rejoinder yeah i don't
know that we know anything that we can
apply any of our normal might not be a
kill switch
sure
great example right what if what if they
built a kill switch in and hasn't been
triggered but you know
i don't know right okay
um so yes
i just got my ccw that's uh we looked it
up concealed carry weapon permit right i
just got my ccw in the mail literally
today
when i went into the multnomah county
office so this is this is someone who
um
went to exactly the same office that you
were in this week that you showed
pictures of when i went to the multnomah
county office to do my paperwork four
months ago it looked identical to the
pictures that you all showed today i
also took pictures it was so surreal
yeah it's almost that's amazing so and i
i really appreciate that because you
know i was left going like uh are we
sure this didn't just happen this week
yeah although the fact that you said and
now
kyle is repeating um that like well he
doesn't say this but you said there were
like literally shards of glass still in
the window pants yeah not shards but
what it was
broken
[Music]
it's crazed i mean that was what you
would call it in pottery but it yeah i i
can't there's some
i mean if a shard can be that big it's a
shard yeah but it but it's not
it's not shards extending into the air
like they're they're entire panes that
are shattered but in place no no it's
like you take a big window and you break
it and some of it crashes to the floor
and some of it remains so it is shards
it is pieces it's not the entire okay so
it is what i thought first i thought you
were saying it wasn't that uh to me
shards mean something smaller but i'm
not convinced i have the definition
right um so if they're leaving they're
leaving
big shards of glass sitting in the
windows
boarded up on one side
on the inside
you're just looking at this broken glass
i mean it's perfect and apparently it's
what it looked like four months ago
right it seems to me that they had an
obligation at the very least just for
safety's sake that you would have to
break out the large pieces of glass
hanging in the window frames
right at the point you were going to
board it up just so that because those
things are now not secure in an
earthquake or who knows but
oh my god
yeah it's completely bizarre
awful
totally different question
how do you recommend urbanites drink
water
tap filter plastic bottles etc
depends on where you live
honestly
because different different urban water
services i don't know i can't think of
what the word is at the moment
we'll treat water differently right so
um
the
the way that water is treated with
fluoride
is um
almost certainly not very good for you
and we've talked about this a little bit
in our book hunter gatherer's guide and
there is an abundant literature on this
um and we are not arguing um that
early on the recognition that that
naturally occurring fluoride in water
wasn't associated with uh fewer cavities
it was this was an honest-to-goodness
observation from if memory serves the
early 20th or late 19th century um but
the particular fluoridation process the
particular fluoride that's put into
water is not that same fluoride and it's
seemingly not very good for you and so
fluoridated water um is
also you can't you can't titrate you
don't like you're not controlling how
much how much you're getting so um
you know a good
drinking water from your tap is a luxury
that we should all be able to enjoy if
we live in places with taps
and so um
if you can
get a filter either for your tap or you
know something to sit on your counter in
your refrigerator or something that
actually filters out the stuff that you
that because of what your particular
urban situation is
what might be in your water supply yeah
i would say
a little chemistry goes a long way here
and
activated charcoal
is kind of marvelous
the basic it's not very complex right
you've got charcoal
the process of activation is a high-tech
process in which they crush it um
that's what activates it kind of sounds
fun actually yeah but basically
it increases
it increases the surface area and the
basic point is that the nature of
charcoal
is that it's polar
right and it has a tremendous number of
nooks and crannies and so the basic idea
is that anything in your water that is
polar will encounter some of the carbon
and stick to it now this works
temporarily if you fill up the carbon so
that all of the surface or most of the
surface has encountered some polar thing
that it has grabbed onto then you will
get weird things like you put some new
polar stuff in there and it can actually
release the stuff that's there if it has
a higher affinity so you want to change
those filters regularly but the basic
point is
a an activated charcoal filter is not
you know if you do something radical
like
reverse osmosis you take out a lot of
the good stuff in your water yes
if you run your water through a basic
filter that
particle-wise will filter out large
things like bacteria and
large things like bacteria
and that filters out uh polar stuff well
if there's some pesticide in your water
it's almost certain to be polar it's
going to get fill it's why is it almost
certain to be polar well it's dissolved
in your water that's if it was an oil it
wouldn't have gotten into your water in
the first place if your water looks
gross to the unaided eye then you got a
different level of problem right
you know go to bottled water but i guess
what i would say is
activated charcoal is the low hanging
fruit right it does a lot of work taking
out
stuff like um
organic compounds that you wouldn't want
to ingest
it doesn't destroy your water
from the point of view of
trace nutrients and things and it's
relatively cheap and relatively easy to
use and doesn't you know fail you know
if you replace it often enough it's
pretty good stuff yeah
i mean we have um portland doesn't
fluoridate water
um so i drink i drink water out of the
tap and we also have a filter
that we use
that we use but you know
neither
neither are we religious about using it
nor do we insist that our children are
and you know obviously the younger you
are the more potentially affected you
will be um by by contaminants um yes i
would also say you mentioned plastic i
would be very concerned about plastics
now there was a kind of moment of
awakening around bpa and so you can
check that things that's one ingredient
right now the fact is this is not hard
work but it drove me crazy when the bpa
uh awareness
jumped that one of the culprit companies
was nalgene
right and that there were all these
nalgene water bottles that had bpa that
leached out into the water and the
answer is nalgene is actually primarily
a lab
ware company yeah which means they have
the ability to know what their plastics
are leaching into the water they can't
possibly been caught off guard so they
allowed it to happen and that that drove
me nuts
and the question is okay so we've
spotted bpa you can very easily run uh
water from
any source that's been sitting in
plastic through a gas chromatograph and
a mass spec and see what's in it so what
we really want is not is it bpa free
it's like is this not leaching anything
into my water right if i treat it badly
if i leave it in the sun does this leak
something into my water that i don't
want to be ingesting that's the answer
you want
and so i would just say i'm hesitant
about plastic i'm doubly hesitant about
plastic that has come in contact with
anything warm
i if you're going to drink out of
plastic you can do yourself a world of
good by
rinsing it
right if there's plastic if you've got
plastic leaching into the water that's
not with hot water right cold water you
rinse it right you'll reduce the amount
of stuff that's there from however long
the water has been sitting on the
surface of it to a tiny fraction and
then you drink from it quickly and the
point is even if it's leaching you won't
get very much yep
all right next question given the
gibraltar fiasco these vaccines don't
work
can we envision a realistic scenario
where establishment dems concede the vax
failure
so neither you nor i were familiar with
the gibraltar fiasco but you pulled up a
thing that um i thought there were two
paragraphs in there that warranted
reading all right yep you have to hand
it to me oh i thought you had it there
no you never shared it with me it's on
your phone oh my god it's on my phone it
really puts the pressure on
uh
yeah i'm a little surprised that neither
of us had heard of the gibraltar fiasco
but um so you brett found this and this
is on rt you said right yep
um
somehow this is now here we go
gibraltar a tiny british overseas
territory sharing a land border with
spain has seen an average of 56 cobia 19
cases per day over the last seven days
up from fewer than 10 per day in
september the rise in cases described by
the government as exponential comes
despite gibraltar having the highest
vaccination rate in the world
point of order um the rising cases
either is or is not exponential the
description of the government has
nothing to do with whether it is i will
continue quoting now
i get off my soapbox
more than 118 percent of gibraltar's
population are fully vaccinated i'm
sorry
all right yeah okay
second paragraph more than 118 percent
of gibraltar's population are fully
vaccinated against covet 19. that's a
lot with this figure stretching beyond
100 due to doses given to spaniards who
cross the border to work or visit the
territory every day
masks are still required in shops and on
public transport
um so they've got
over 100
compliance
somehow that's that's some interesting
math um but uh the rate of daily doses
is five
five times what it was um before so
that's the given the gibraltar fiasco
that's the that's the background on that
question these vaccines don't work can
we envision a real realistic scenario
where establishment dems concede the
backs failure
it is almost impossible to imagine the
concession it is not impossible to
imagine the recognition
on the public's part
so i would just say you know we are here
absent concession though if the public
sorry but if the public starts to wake
up maybe because they refuse to take
boosters or whatever
how will the dems
what will they do in the next election
uh well now you've asked the question
what will the dems do in the next
election that's a question no matter
what true um
for so many reasons but
um
look
i don't think these people have a game
plan
i do think they're gonna keep
you know
will they admit that these vaccines um
don't work
i find that very unlikely
will they probably too late to pin them
on trump even though they were developed
entirely under the trump now they're
going to pin the failure of the vaccines
on the unvaccinated and amazing fact in
and of itself
and they will pivot to some other policy
it will be unclear it will continue to
be unclear what their objective is right
in fact that absolutely maddening
article
from the wall street journal
makes the amazing claim that part of the
problem with the vaccines is that the
people who released them
botched
the communication and they led people to
think that the purpose of the vaccines
was to control the pandemic rather than
to rever to reduce extreme reactions to
covet
right
[Music]
sorry
so i haven't read this article um
if that's true
if that were true how can you have that
position and the unvaccinated causing
this and uh you can't put those two
things next to it and the mandates
because to the extent that their point
is oh this is for reducing uh
hospitalizations then the point is then
this really is a question of personal
choice
right the only argument for the mandates
if if that is actually an accurate
description of you know oh this is we
knew this all along this is what it's
actually yes
but but then
then it's not a public health thing
right it has nothing to do with public
health right this is this is the
government trying to make sure that you
have the best chance because you need
this well no thanks government i'm good
would of course be a legitimate
responsibility i mean think about it
this way this is the nanny state
and think about what a terrible nanny
state it is because
why the hell are we vaccinating children
then
that's what nannies do
if it ain't about preventing
transmission
vaccinating kids who are healthy and
don't have any risk from this disease
doesn't make any sense well so i mean
that
if you're quoting that article right if
they've got some
monkey muk public health
official saying
we always knew pfizer always knew that
like the manufacturer the vaccines
always knew that it wasn't going to
affect transmission
that actually changes everything they
didn't say that but um
believe me there's no way
to square this circle right and so your
question
um
about
what what will the democrats do if this
start if the public response starts to
be wait um
i think the thing is it's an escalator
of mendacity and we are is that a thing
yeah we just made that up no i wish i
had but escalator of mendacity yeah i
like that um the point is they are going
to keep
lying
right in order not to take
responsibility for having massively
screwed this up which they clearly have
no matter what you believe you can see
that they massively screwed it up right
this this is not what we were promised
and it isn't doing what they told us it
would do and gibraltar is a very good
demonstration of that
right so you know we've had this problem
where
as the rate of vaccination goes up
the fraction of the people who get covid
who are vaccinated goes up
there is something ominous in that but
it's not inherently ominous because at
the point that you get to 100 vaccinated
population then everybody who gets the
case will be a breakthrough but
what this does show is that that is not
effective at controlling the disease
right which then raises a question about
everything they've done yep
worse than state lines an alarming
number of people think that written
houses victims were black and the media
political complex violates its own
misinformation guidelines by not pushing
back yep i've seen this i've seen it
actually reported in like uh
you know the bullet points under a
headline
it's like this is just
it's just it's like just
it's just
the fact checkers are too busy getting
things wrong elsewhere is that the
problem yeah yeah oh man
fact check has become an utterly ironic
term i think we're at about an hour is
that right zach
um
okay let's do one more
okay
i notice you don't wear your bandana
anymore has your view on them changed
yeah um
it has changed i mean let's put it this
way the evidence that masks are
effective
is pretty thin
to the extent that there is evidence
that masks are effective cloth masks do
not appear to be so i got that wrong
um
so
well i've just started defaulting to an
n95 mask which i also we just have a box
of them it's not that oh we really need
like we just i bought a box i just feel
like if i'm gonna they come in their own
little thing and they're easy to pack
and whatever yeah
they're all right um and they look
they're black they like they're subtle
so
yes my position has changed on these
things i think the irony is
um there is a hierarchy of how
utterly ineffective they are
and um bandana is
you know look well okay so but
i i have not gone deep into the mask
literature the mask advocacy literature
surgeons and surgical staff wear masks
during surgeries yep
other hospital staff during
non-surgeries are also masked to go into
certain
rooms and wards for instance tb i
believe
i think that's true
is there the suggestion that masks
aren't effective against something like
tuberculosis either it's not a general
mass don't work for anything right so so
um
you know if you're going to be stuck
wearing a mask in the grocery store in
january in portland or november as it is
given that all sorts of other things
are seasonal and you're more likely to
get them now maybe because you have less
vitamin d maybe because you're spending
more time inside whatever
um wearing a mask that actually has
greater efficacy against other things
whether or not it actually has any
efficacy here
if you're i mean i i'm not gonna start
shopping in the grocery store and mask
someone i don't have to you know for
that for that reason um but
but you might as well make it as
effective as possible i guess
um
yeah i'm not sure that any of the things
that you might pick up at the
supermarket are going to be effectively
controlled by this if it's not an exotic
thing and you know
how much surgeons wear them uh you know
to prevent you know
bacteria
from landing in a patient or something
um but
yeah
yeah a person that's been opened
surgically is at a much different kind
of risk yeah an attack human being
walking around so i will say
the problem is that the bandana always
did have some very real advantages right
because you could wear it around your
neck and pull it up it was much less of
a hassle it actually doesn't fog the
glasses in the same way because there's
more room for air to go down
so it's a superior version of a mask the
mask like on your face right over your
nose is bad for glasses it's
it's particularly uncomfortable and
particularly confining and so
um
also a facial hair will obviously
interfere with the efficacy of masks yes
it will yes it will absolutely yeah
all right this has been a weird day yeah
it has been a weird day it's been a
weird day we've had a lot of cat visits
uh
maybe
maybe we're there
yep i think we're there you were there
uh we'll be back next week after
thanksgiving
uh for episode 106
who knows what we'd be talking about
then in the meantime um consider joining
us at either of our patreons uh picking
up a copy of hunter gatherer's guide to
21st century
coming over to natural selections my
substance where i'm talking about higher
ed these days and
a little bit about thanksgiving i posted
something yesterday about thanksgiving
and some of our some of our traditions
um
oh what else
oh the um welcome to complex systems a
shirt is now available at the store
i couldn't tell you where to find the
store oh there it's still it's on the
start of coursepodcast.org
stores.org darkhorsepodcast.org
and we'll be getting a few more things
up and we'll show you about them next
week in the meantime
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you